I like to ask whether or not you have goals, but I wanna ask you another question.
How many of you know that if you had your life to live over again, you could do more than what you've done this far?
Raise your hands, please.
Now, that proves the point that what we do and what we accomplish in life is only a tip of the iceberg of what's possible for us.
So, I want you to think about some goals that you like to achieve and I like for you to, let's say break them up in three categories.
Number one, I want you to think about some personal goal you'd like to achieve.
And I like for you to think about some career goal, some business goal that you'd like to achieve.
And why don't you think about some social contribution?
Some impact you'd like to make with your life.
It was Horace Mann who said, "We should be ashamed to die until we've made some major contribution to humankind."
I believe we live in the greatest country in the world that gives us an opportunity to leave our mark,...
...to make a statement with our lives.
And as you think about these goals, whatever those goals are, I want you to dramatically increase those goals and...
...I wanna warn you, I don't want you to think about how you're going to do it.
How is none of your business.
The most important thing is just to increase those goals dramatically.
I found that most people fail in life not because they aim too high and miss.
Most people fail in life because they aim too low and hit,...
..and many don't aim at all.